Mr Speaker the member for South
Staffordshire told a civil servant to
Slit their throat
how does the Prime Minister think the
victim of that bullying felt when he
expressed great sagness at his
resignation
equivocally the behavior complained of
was unacceptable and it is absolutely
right it is absolutely right that the
right honorable gentleman has resigned
for the record I did not know about any
of the specific concerns relating to his
conduct as Secretary of State or chief
whip which date back some years I
believe that people in public life
should treat others with consideration
and respect and those other principles
that this government will stand by
[Applause]
uh Mr Speaker the member for South
Staffordshire spent years courting the
idea he can intimidate others blurring
the lines to normalize bullying Behavior
it's precisely why the Prime Minister
gave him a job the truth is simple he's
a pathetic bully but he would never get
away with it if people like the Prime
Minister didn't hand him power
so does he regret his decision to make
him a government minister
foreign
Mr Speaker I obviously regret appointing
someone who has had to resign in these
circumstances
but I think
conditions like this arise that they
will be dealt with properly
do they write that there is an
investigation to look into these matters
properly I said my government would be
characterized by Integrity
professionalism and account visibility
and it will
[Applause]
Mr Speaker everyone in the country knows
someone like the member for South
Staffordshire a sad middle manager
getting off on intimidating those
beneath him but everyone in the country
also knows someone like the Prime
Minister the boss who is so weak so
worried the bullies will turn on him
that he hides behind them
what message does he think it sends when
rather than take on the bullies he lines
up alongside them and thanks them for
their loyalty
amazing
[Applause]
Mr Speaker the message that I clearly
want to send is that Integrity in public
life matters
and that is why that is why it is right
that the right honorable member has
resigned it is why it is right that
there is a rigorous process to examine
these issues
as well as focusing on this one
individual it is also right and
important that we keep delivering for
the whole country and that's why this
government will continue to concentrate
on stabilizing the economy on
strengthening the NHS and or tackling
illegal migration those are my
priorities those are the priorities of
the British people and this government
will deliver on them
Mr Speaker the problem is he can't stand
up to a run-of-the-mill bully yeah so he
has no chance of standing up to vested
interests on behalf of working people
take shell they made record profits this
year 26 billion pounds how much have
they paid under his so-called windfall
tax yes
Mr Speaker I was Chancellor who
introduced an extra attacks on the oil
and gas companies right but and he talks
he talks Mr Speaker he talks about
working people the right Arnold member
he voted he voted against legislation to
stop extremist protesters disrupting
working people
that's because he's not on the side of
working people Mr Speaker that's what
the conservatives are for
Mr Speaker I'm against all of those
courts in chaos damage to our public
services and to our economy whether they
are gluing themselves to the road or
sitting on the government benches
speaker there was no answer to the
question because the answer is nothing
shall haven't paid a penny in Windfall
tax
why because for every pound they spend
digging for fossil fuels he hands them a
90p tax break and it's costing the
taxpayer billions
so will he find a backbone and end his
absurd oil and gas giveaway
[Applause]
oh Mr Speaker what the party opposite
will never understand is that its
businesses investing that create jobs in
this country
[Music]
the side of the house we understand that
we will support businesses to invest to
create jobs because that's how we create
Prosperity that's how we support strong
public services and that's what you get
with a conservative government
[Applause]
there's only one party that crashed the
economy and they're all sitting there
[Applause]
prime minister too weak to sack the
security threat sat around the cabinet
table too weak to take part in a
leadership contest after he lost the
first one too weak to stand up for
working people
he spent weeks flirting with the climate
change deniers in his party then
scuffled off to cop at the last minute
yeah a budget next week he'll be too
weak to end his oil and gas giveaway
scrap the non-dom tax breaks and end the
farce of taxpayers subsidizing private
schools that's what labor would do a
proper plan for working people Mr
Speaker if he can't even stand up to a
cartoon bully with a pet spider yes if
he's too scared to face the public in an
election what chance has he got of
running the country
we won't we want to try and get through
on time and I know some members want to
catch my eye they're not doing a good
job so far come on prime minister
of a gentleman talks about judgment
about putting people around the cabinet
table I would just gently remind him he
thought the member for Islington North
with the right person to look after our
security
but Mr Speaker The Honorable gentleman
The Honorable gentleman is he said a lot
today he said a lot today but it's clear
that he isn't focused on the serious
issues that are confronting our country
we're strengthening our economy he's
backing the strikers we're supporting
people with energy bills he's supporting
the protesters and we're tackling
illegal migration he's opposing every
measure the British people want real
leadership on the serious Global
challenges we face and that's what
they'll get from this government
[Applause]